si mon lolo l'équipe est là oui c'est
parti tu peux nous les présenter à qui
ce soit autour de la table montchanin
j'ai fait un truc façon grosse tête en
vitesse en angoisse à la naissance une
fille lui a proposé l'intelligence de sa
grand mère ou la tronche de son père je
crois qu'il a fait le mauvais choix
benjamins 4
[Applaudissements]
j'aime en allemand depuis que son patin
je suis à bloquer tout le train arrière
on l'appelle le labrador
[Applaudissements]
il a plus souvent ont grimpé la dune du
pilat que le col de l'utérus
[Applaudissements]
si tu dises des infos dans sa
présentation non même quand il fait une
fellation matthieu delormeau articule
plus que lui maxime gagné jamais des
shows nidal
j'étais pas là je te plait pas je t'ai
pas le toit à chaque intervention elle
relance le débat sur l'euthanasie
isabelle moret je me dis souligna aussi
c'est pas fini si elles ouvraient une
banque du sperme les donneurs ferait là
que haga topo
[Applaudissements]
català je suis pas là j'ai pas la brésil
car niche annonça sa série des alertes
c'est ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jackson je lui malaise mais ça va c'est
pas très dur tout ce qu'il a dit en
anglais cette fois
je reconnais que ça en thani seulement
bébé à chaque fois qu'il met au but il
se fait greffer un cheveu jean-michel si
ses coups de reins étaient à la hauteur
de ses coups de gueule il serait déjà
mariée elle est toujours derrière elle
est toujours derrière c'est dur à dire
elle est toujours derrière cyril mais un
jour ce sera l'un vers ce qu'elle est et
pour finir mon frère a déconné il croit
que c est ça signifie cheikh sommes
astronomiques cyril hanouna
[Applaudissements]